[Applauso]
quando eravamo bambini
tutto intorno a noi era avvolto da un
alone di magia delle cose semplicissime
come una scatola di cartone potevano
diventare speciali potevano diventare un
razzo più laboratorio di idee
il kosar e il fare disfare provare e
riprovare con le cose è il modo
principale con quei bambini conoscono la
realtà imparano con gli altri
ma facciamo un piccolo viaggio insieme
voglio invitarvi a chiudere gli occhi a
fare un respiro profondo e andare
indietro nel tempo
siete appena tornati da scuola a casa la
merenda è quasi pronta e andate verso la
vostra camera
lì ci sono tutti i vostri giocattoli e
in particolare uno giocavate con il quel
giocattolo così tanto ve lo ricordate
prendete quel giocattolo le toccate lo
guardate lo ri mirate non usate magari
quel giocattolo prendeva vita come in
toy story e rimandava a fare grandi
esplorazioni o magari quel giocattolo lo
avete rotto spaccato ricostruito per
imparare come era fatto
o magari ha fatto fare amicizia con
altri bambini o litigare quanto era
bello al cosaro un altro respiro
profondo e riapriamo gli occhi il cosare
è molto importante nella scuola ed è
molto importante per i bambini piccoli
se pensate per fantastici mattoncini
della lego a quanti momenti di cosare ci
hanno dato
ma il cosare scema
via via che entriamo nella scuola
elementare e si fa spazio più a lezioni
frontali
ai libri alle elezioni al classico
imparare ad alcuni lavoratori ma molto
meno al creare al fare o disfare a
imparare dall'esperienza e oggi la
tecnologia comincia anche a far parte
della scuola elementare e computer
le applicazioni sui tablet e negli
ultimi tempi i robot i robot sociali per
poi trovare l'insegnamento per aiutare i
bambini ad imparare di più magari un po
meglio per essere più motivati per
essere più fiduciosi
quando ho cominciato la mia ricerca in
olanda 7 anni fa mi era fondato una
sfida la mia sfida era quella di
sviluppare un robot per la
collaborazione tra i bambini
nell'insegnamento scolastico sono una
scienziata cognitiva
conosco perfettamente come funziona il
nostro cervello i nostri comportamenti e
mi interessa capire come l'esperienza
del mondo
l'interazione con le altre persone
influisce sui nostri comportamenti e il
cervello e pensavo che questa mia
preparazione fosse fondamentale per
riuscire a sviluppare una robotica
migliore per riuscire a sopportare
l'insegnamento dei bambini a far
diventare più bravi a scuola e
competenti che quello che vogliamo per i
nostri bambini vero bene anche io come i
miei colleghi
volevo un robot che fosse un maestro che
insegnasse motivasse e facesse a
diventare i bambini più competenti più
bravi mai avrei pensato che i miei primi
passi nella ricerca potesse essere così
disastrosi e beh si erano veramente
disastrose ho cominciato a fare i primi
esperimenti con i bambini in olanda
nelle scuole e utilizzavo il mio robot
che supportava la collaborazione nei
giochi di geometria e per quanto i
risultati non fossero male dal punto di
vista scientifico tv di collaboravano
erano attenti erano motivati tutto bene
peccato che chiacchierando con i bambini
mi sono resa conto
che i bambini erano un pochino
spaventate dal robot non si trovava un
orologio una bambina mi ha detto lo sai
questo robot è come una maestra ma
maestra un po strana un po lenta non so
cosa fare non so come comportarmi altri
bambini erano così stupiti da come un
robot si comportava in maniera strana
che lo prendevano in giro e io ho
cominciato a chiedermi non mi sembra che
questa cosa stia funzionando mi sa che
si manda nella direzione sbagliata
questo non è il modo in cui io voglio
aiutare i bambini ad imparare meglio e
dall'innovazione all'educazione eroina
una grandissima crisi e in questa crisi
è cominciato a pensare ok come
funzionano i bambini come vogliono
crescere cosa vogliono fare e ho
ripensato a me stessa quando ero piccola
e qua mi vedete piccola e molte città di
andare a scuola il mio primo giorno di
scuola
la notte prima e quello che pensavo e
che in effetti a me piaceva fare disfare
mi piaceva imparare con le cose
soprattutto le materie astratte la
matematica la fisica e ricordo molto
bene il giorno in cui ho tagliato le
tende della mia classe a scuola perché
volevo imparare a capire come funziona
astori fasci di luce cosa altro fare se
non tagliare le tende ma certamente quel
fare cosare era importante ma poi mi
sono auto regolata lo distanziato da me
negli anni e durante i miei studi e
adesso che ci pensavo
magari quel cosare quella volontà di
sperimentare fare con le cose migliori
per i tantissimi in questo momento di
crisi soprattutto mi avrebbe aiutato a
capire come andare avanti che tipo di
soluzione trovare
e mi sono resa conto che questa non è
solo la mia personale esperienza tutti
voi e tutti i bambini hanno una crisi
creativa passata dall asilo elementari
perdono quella naturale tendenza
sperimentare quel naturale essere
scienziato cosa
ed è una cosa tristissima e mi chiedevo
perché non lavorare su questo
invece di cercare di replicare un robot
come un maestro perché non lavorare sul
cosare e dentro di me c'era un grande no
no non voglio andare avanti con questo
tende rogo sociali che sembrano maestri
non mi sembra la strada giusta
cosa posso fare per sviluppare un robot
per la collaborazione e cercarlo e
cercare di farlo nella maniera più
naturale nella maniera in cui bambini
naturalmente imparano quindi tramite il
cosare era in olanda ed ero disperata
non sapevo cosa fare e ha trovato una
risposta ma questa risposta non parlava
olandese
una risposta che parlava italiano mi
stata avvicinata al metodo montessoriano
e gli insegnamenti di quel grande
designer italiano e milanese che era
bruno munari entrambi credevano molto
nell'importanza del giocare assieme con
dei con degli oggetti fatti ad hoc per
imparare le cose non conduzioni
dall'alto in basso ma facendo quindi dal
basso verso l'alto e quello che ho fatto
è stato andare ad osservare come i nelle
tante scuole randisi dove gli
insegnamenti montessoriani e di munari
sugli implementati i bambini lavorano
tra di loro imparano e ho visto che
tanti oggetti tante cose che utilizzano
lì come se fossero la carta e la penna
su il modo migliore per i bambini di
imparare tante cose della matematica la
fisica a come collaborare a come vivere
a sé ma come essere empatici gli oggetti
e lavorare con gli altri e il nozionismo
sono i pilastri dell'educazione
montessoriana e di prono monari e bruno
munari diceva per capire il mondo dei
bambini ti devi sedere accanto i bambini
osservarli non disturbarli e lasciarli
fare e in questo modo ho capito come
continuare
ho trovato la mia
soluzione è il mio modo di andare avanti
per la mia ricerca ho cominciato a
lavorare sulle robot cose le rubo cose
era un'idea per portare avanti nuovi
oggetti per l'educazione gli oggetti
montessoriani e le attività di munari
erano rivoluzionarie e ha pensato perché
non portare questa rivoluzione nella
robotica utilizzare quella grande
possibilità che robot citando di rendere
le cose interattive di comunicare a
livello sociale ed interagire con i
bambini di applicare strategie nel
cosare e utilizzare gli oggetti invece
di replicare gli umani e i lavoratori
con bambini ho cominciato a sviluppare
le loro cose con tanti bambini olandese
americani e tedeschi
ho lavorato per capire cosa sono le loro
cose del robot cose sono cose mattoncini
parte di costruzioni giocattoli e come
tale interagiscono del gioco non ti
dicono cosa fare cosa non fare ma
semplicemente giocando quel bambino e
fanno azioni in particolari momenti i
momenti in cui i bambini non sanno come
collaborare non si aiutano lui o
quell'altro e magari litigano
condividono cose portano via le cose e
simona nello spazio durante il gioco
e in quel modo dal basso
fanno riflettere il bambino sulle se
comportamenti che deve avere durante la
collaborazione le robot cose non sono
come degli umani a differenza dei robot
sociali non sono di fattura umana non
hanno elementi a trovo morti che vuol
dire avere una faccia guerra una bocca
si muovono come cose e bambini si
rapportano con loro come tali inoltre le
robot cose sono inclusive nel robot cose
sono fatte in maniera semplice di
materiali robusti
di colori tenui senza lucette fastidiose
senza suoni che siano troppo alti o
troppo bambino xi diciamo in questo modo
i bambini che hanno anche difficoltà
sensoriali possono approcciarsi alle
robot cose o i bambini che non sentono
possono processo le rogo cose allo
stesso modo il robot cose non sono per
bambino o per bambina non hanno che fare
con gli stereotipi di genere sono per
tutti le robot cose non parlano del
robot cose fanno si muovono e non
utilizzando il linguaggio fanno sì che
tutti i bambini che non possono parlare
ai bambini che non parlano perché sono
non verbali possono giocare con gli
altri bambini e in questo modo essere
veramente inclusivi
allo stesso modo le rovo cose sono
robotiche quindi sono autonome hanno un
margine di autonomia sanno cosa fare
quando cercano di fare un modello dei
comportamenti del bambino e rispondere
ma per fare ciò non lo fanno in maniera
totalmente autonoma c'è sempre il
controllo del bambino
il bambino è il protagonista del giocare
del kosar e non il robot in questo modo
sia una vera educazione dal basso verso
l'altro e non calato dall'alto ma cosa
cosa non e robot cose
beh voglio darmi un esempio da una
ricerca che ho effettuato con dei
colleghi europei
abbiamo sviluppato insieme un robot per
il riordino e tramite il riordino
tramite il gioco del riordino coadiuvava
la collaborazione tra i bambini
abbiamo osservato per almeno tre mesi
bambini giocare con questa roba cosa
una robot cosa che cercava di aiutare a
collaborare tramite condivisione tramite
lo sviluppo e la volontà la reciprocità
bene le prime due settimane in cui per
robot cosa giocava coi bambini da robot
cosa non interagivo che bambini e
bambini giocavano da soli non hanno mai
cercato di collaborare anche se
collaborare sarebbe stato vantaggioso
per finire prima il gioco per farlo
diventare più divertente
nel momento in cui la roba cosa ha
cominciato a condividere oggetti con una
dei bambini
la bambina a reciprocato al robot e allo
stesso modo gli altri uomini che
osservavano la bambina hanno cominciato
a collaborare tra di loro con la bambina
e con il robot sono piccole piccole cose
ma che fanno una grande differenza
e questi risultati sono sorprendenti e
questi grandi risultati hanno portato
lontano e mi hanno portato a credere in
questa idea nella portato alla cornelli
diversi ti devo sviluppato insieme ad
altri colleghi un nuovo robot cosa pu
swan che è fatta per coadiuvare la
collaborazione e per cercare di aiutare
i bambini a non litigare è semplicemente
ebbe data il piccoli giochi di puzzle
come quelli che vedete in queste
immagini e ci sto ancora lavorando molto
su questa roba cosa ma i risultati sono
importanti e sono sorprendenti
quello che ho imparato nei miei nella
mia ricerca tra l'italia e l'america
l'olanda è che le robot cose possono
portare al futuro dei giocattoli per
bambini al futuro dell'educazione non
per fare ciò dobbiamo fare in modo di
dare lo spazio ai bambini a loro modo di
essere a loro modo di imparare
in una parola al loro modo di posare
perché è importante che ogni bambino
porti la propria esperienza nel mondo e
dobbiamo distaccarci completamente da
quella tecnologia che vuole farci
diventare più meccanici più produttivi
sempre all'erta
dobbiamo abbracciare le imperfezioni
la tecnologia che ci porta anche a
sbagliare qualche volta a provare a
riprovare a pasticciare in una parola la
tecnologia per posare per farci scoprire
la nostra umanità che imperfetta ad
accompagnarci in quell avventura
fantastica che crescere
[Applauso]